und in den Mediatheken von ARD und ZDF
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum internationalen
Frühschoppen live aus Köln an diesem
Sonntagmittag es ist Ferienzeit aber die
Sorgen um die großen Krisen die nehmen
keine Auszeit wir schauen nach Spanien
dort wird heute sogar gewählt möglich
ist ein Machtwechsel nach rechts aber
nicht nur dort sondern auch in vielen
anderen europäischen Ländern dominieren
die Debatten um Flucht und Migration die
politische Auseinandersetzung in den
Niederlanden stürzte die Regierung
darüber die AFD erhält in Deutschland
immer mehr Zustimmung in Ungarn Polen
Schweden und Italien sind
Rechtspopulisten bereits in
Regierungsverantwortung die EU ringt
seit Jahren um eine gemeinsame
Flüchtlingspolitik Streit um Asyl rückt
Europa weiter nach rechts darüber
spreche ich in der nächsten Stunde mit
meinen Gästen und gerne später auch mit
ihnen ich begrüße ganz herzlich Edith
all Thai sie ist freie Journalistin aus
Ungarn sie lebt in Berlin und arbeitet
für das Berliner Korrespondentenbüro für
Deutschland hier am Tisch Wolfram Weimer
Publizist und Verleger für die
Niederland
mossinghoff sie ist auslandsredakteurin
des niederländischen Rundfunks nos in
Hilversum und am Wahlsonntag zu uns aus
Madrid gekommen ist Aurora minguez sie
war mehr als 20 Jahre lang Journalistin
und Korrespondentin für rtve das ist der
spanische öffentliche rechtliche
Rundfunk und war auch Korrespondentin in
Deutschland
formenges wir schauen nach Spanien heute
um 20 Uhr schließen glaube ich die
Wahllokale was erwarten Sie und wie
erklären Sie den Zuspruch jetzt laut
allen Umfragen eben für die Partido
Popular also die konservative
also wie es finden uns in ein solchen
waldmoment wo Spanien nicht noch nach
rechts
gehen sollte sondern zum ersten Mal in
40 Jahren so eine rechtskonservative
Partei in der Regierung von Madrid
kommen kann also die boxpartei die
heißen Box also wie Stimme
sie sind schon präsent in mehrere
regional Regierungen und haben schon
gezeigt wie gefährlich sie sein können
die große Frage ist heute ob
albertonunias also der Führer von diese
konservative Partei PB in der Lage ist
eine absolute Mehrheit zu bekommen
denn sanchismus weg zu schieben und
jetzt steht fest genau
also diese Philosophie von Federer
sanche und seine alliierte
also wie gesagt die Frage ist
weg geht und ob die PP also die
Konservativen allein regieren können
oder ob sie ob sie die Konservativen
eigentlich diese Rechtsextremisten
brauche und das kann enorme Konsequenzen
nicht nur viel Spanien sondern für
Europa haben weil Spanien ja im Moment
auch die Ratspräsidentschaft hat darüber
sprechen wir gleich natürlich noch mal
ausführlich aber versuchen wir erstmal
hier ein bisschen am Tisch zu sortieren
wie die Positionen in den einzelnen
Ländern sind in den Niederlanden ist der
Ministerpräsident hat gesagt er will
nicht mehr weitermachen die Regierung
ist zerbrochen und ministerpräsidentisch
steht auch nicht mehr zur Wahl wenn im
Herbst gewählt wird dass die Regierung
ist gestürzt über das Thema Migration
also wie wichtig ist dieses Thema Flucht
und Migration in ihrem Land das Thema
ist sehr wichtig vor allem seit dem
letzten Jahr dann kam so viele
Flüchtlinge nach den Niederlanden das zu
wenige Bette gab und man kennt
vielleicht sind auch über die Welt
gegangen
die Flüchtlinge hätten unter dem klaren
Himmel schlafen müssen und seitdem ist
die Frage von Asyl und Flüchtlinge die
in den Niederlanden und auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern immer wieder
zurückkommt mehr aktuell geworden sind
das zu viele manche finden ja andere
finden nicht und das hat in die
gestürzte Regierung zu eine Krise
geführt wo die Regierung hatte
weit führende Pläne um die Richtlinien
für Flüchtlinge und Migranten strikte zu
machen und einige Tage vor dem stürzt
der Regierung hat die VVD die Partei von
Margarete noch eine extra etwas extra
zugelegt und eigentlich gefordert dass
sie Familiennachzug sehr stark
eingeschränkt werden muss und das hat
dann dazu geführt dass die Regierung
gestürzt ist und er führt auch zu neu
waren in November und darüber das ist
dann sicherlich auch eines der Themen
die unter anderem waren entscheidend
wenn man nach Deutschland schaut die AFD
im Umfrage hoch in den letzten Umfragen
von infraretest die man kommt sie auf 20
Prozent wie stark denken Sie haben diese
20 Prozent auch mit dem Thema Asyl und
Migration zu tun sehr stark es gibt ja
dazu auch Umfragen nach den Motiven der
AFD will auch der vielen neuen afd-welle
und die geben an mit großem Abstand ihr
wichtigstes Motiv ist Migration und
Migrationspolitik für Deutschland ist es
wirklich ein Kipppunkt seine politischen
Geschichte denn wenn diese Partei die
jahrelang am schmuddeligen rechten Rand
verortet war und auch überschaubar klein
geblieben ist nun erst die Liberalen
überholt dann die Grünen überholt jetzt
sogar die Sozialdemokraten überholt und
nach neuen Umfragen nah an die CDU
herankommt dann verändert dass die
Architektur unsere Republik und das ist
etwas Gravierendes und ich bin irritiert
warum unsere Bundesregierung unser
Bundeskanzler das nicht adressiert also
diese gewaltige brodelnde Stimmung im
Land die offenbar Grund dafür ist nicht
aufnimmt und sagt okay wir machen
folgenden Aktionsplan oder man man nimmt
es zumindest zu Kenntnis und dieser
Kipppunkt den erleben wir auch in Europa
es ist ja im Grunde genommen ein
flächendeckendes Phänomen wir haben ja
auch jetzt große Länder wie Italien die
von Rechtspopulisten regiert werden wenn
heute in Frankreich gewählt würde würde
Frau schlagen und jetzt werden wir in
Spanien heute weil das Erachtens auch
ein Rechtsruck erleben ich glaube
übrigens dass das heiße Wetter in
Spanien den Rechtsruck noch ein Stück
befördern wird
traditionellerweise der Süden eher links
wählt der Norden eher rechts und im
Süden ist es sehr heiß und es geht heute
auch darum die kernwählerschaft zu
mobilisieren und dann Sozialisten Fällen
genau dieses Datum gewählt ja also die
Wahlen vorgezogen
können und dann muss man sagen wenn wir
sprechen über Rechtsruck in Europa
möglicherweise ist es auch eine Links
Politik ist ja immer ein ein Spiel der
Relativitäten warum auf einmal so viele
Millionen Europäer rechtswellen oder
sogar ganz rechts wählen hat ja auch
damit zu tun dass die das politische
Angebot der Linken offenbar nicht mehr
als attraktiv empfunden wird ein Land
das schon länger rechts wählt und wo
recht obwohl es muss einfach ganz klar
in der Regierungsverantwortung ist es
das Land von Viktor Aumann Ungarn Frau
Alter erklären Sie uns mal warum das so
ist warum man in Ungarn z.B bei der
Flüchtlingspolitik so restriktiv ist so
viel stärker als alle anderen
europäischen Länder ich würde das mal in
einen Kontext schon und ich wieder mal
die Spaltung der EU-Länder über diese
Frage Migration anschleppen und mal
versuchen zu erklären warum das ist
nicht nur in Ungarn sondern ich würde
mal meinen in der Mitte ist europäischen
Länder auch in den neuen Bundesländer
ist der ist dieser Tendenz größer als im
Westen und äh da würde ich mal darauf
hinweisen oder die Spaltung nicht so da
ist auf der einen Seite oder Ungarn und
andere Länder lehnen Migration überhaupt
ab auf der anderen Seite im Westen sind
sie für offene Grenzen dass die die
Menschen kommen und ich denke die ganze
Mentalität ist hier anders in Ungarn und
anderen Ländern und zwar
eine große Rolle hat Kommunismus
gespielt dass sie haben
und
Ungarn möchte für sich von der EU also
so behandelt als als wäre diese
Souveränität wie soll ich sagen
gefährdet also es ist eine Souveränität
also irgendwann fühlt sich in seiner
Souveränität bedroht wird sagen bekommt
aber natürlich sehr viel Geld aus der
von der EU da hat lange
im Moment aber hat lange Zeit ja sehr
profitiert von der EU und trotzdem diese
ist diese Entwicklung sofort
sind wir da ist Ungarn und andere
Ländern
sehen in diesen offenen Grenzen
eigentlich eine existenzielle Bedrohung
also zuerst für den Staat als deutsches
dann für die nationale Identität und
überhaupt einige
sagen auch die europäische Zivilisation
ist gefährdet und sehr sehr viele
Menschen teilen diese Meinung es ist
eine existenzielle Sache und für die
aber nicht gilt für die Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine denn da hat Ungarn viele
aufgenommen sich nicht bedroht nein weil
das ist ein Nachbarland müssen sie
vorstellen die Ukraine ist ein
Nachbarland und dieser Menschen flüchten
so auseinander Ungarn und sie wurden da
war nie eine Frage das werden aus einem
Nachbarland kommt und vor dem Krieg
führte dass dann
dass dieser Menschen aufgenommen werden
auch so wird er ganz klar unterschieden
welche Menschen zu Ihnen kommen
die Pläne der gestößere Regierung gingen
in die Richtung man wollte einen
Unterschied machen zwischen politisch
geflüchtete und Kriegsflüchtlinge wovon
man behauptet eines Tages gehen die
wieder zurück und man wollte wenn es um
Familiennachzug geht wollte man auch die
Möglichkeiten für Kriegsflüchtlinge
beschränken
was man auch gesehen hat letztes Jahr
eine Niederlande ist das Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine großzügig aufgenommen sind
das waren um 25% der neu zu uns
gekommenen und das ist nie ein Problem
gewesen also da ist sich die ist sich
Europa einig sozusagen in der
Unterstützung der Ukraine ist es in
ihrem Land also wie schaut man da auf
der das ganze Thema Migration welche
Rolle spielte das
also in dieser Wahlkampf überhaupt keine
man hat sehr wenig über Europa
gesprochen sehr viel über Blödsinn und
Lügen und haltbar halten ein bisschen
über Wirtschaft aber über Europa
Präsidentschaft oder Migration
eigentlich wenn ich oder nichts also zum
Beispiel wie kommt das
ich glaube das ist eine Sache von
Müdigkeit zuerst also die Leute in
Spanien sind müde von die beiden großen
Parteien
die Leute glauben also die kümmern sich
nicht um unsere Probleme dazu kommt
diese Polarisierung dazu kommt auch
diese boxpartei dass dieses Klima total
vergiftet hat mit große Parolen ohne ein
fester Programm mit diese Schlagzeile
also die Frauen sind von dieser
Regierung gefährdet worden oder
also die Ausländer die kommen und nehmen
alles an
das Problem ist eigentlich das in Europa
Patrioten wir brauchen also als ob die
normale
Parteien nicht vertreten wären
also es wurde eigentlich sehr wenig über
seriöse Themen gesprochen also die die
spanische Präsidentschaft hat im Moment
überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt und wenn
wir über Migration sprechen dann ich
finde besonders gefährlich wenn die
Konservativen mittwochs reagieren
sollten dann sollte man die Box Ideen
auch mitnehmen und diese Ideen heißen
zum Beispiel Blockaden für mit Migranten
die aus den mittelmärkten nach Spanien
kommen
Abschottung von Europa also überhaupt
keine manitäre Geschichte
was noch
also kein Geld für Migranten und wenn
wir Migranten aufnehmen sollten dann nur
aus Lateinamerika weil sie sich bei uns
besser fühlen und es gibt kein Probleme
mit der Sprache wir haben nur kleine
auch genommen ja aber nicht so viele wir
sehen ja in schon vielen Ländern Europas
oder in den meisten halt eben dass man
einfach mit diesem Problem nicht so
recht kommt dass und das ist dass die
das viele überfordert sind damit aber
vor allen Dingen eben überfordert sind
mit Menschen die aus Afrika kommen die
aus Syrien kommen aus diesen Ländern ist
es richtig dass man da so ein
Unterschied macht das die Europäische
Union sagt wir müssen die Menschen
unterschiedlich behandeln ich glaube ja
also wenn sie Deutschland ansprechen die
Stimmung in Deutschland den Flüchtlingen
aus der Ukraine gegenüber ist zum
Beispiel überwältigen positiv also das
ist auch ein massenhafter
hilfsreflex der bis in die Kommunen und
in die Familie hineingeben das ist auch
unstrittig und provoziert auch keine
Ablehnung es ist etwas anderes wenn sie
Hunderttausende von jungen muslimischen
Männern aus dem arabischen Raum
nach Deutschland holen oder nach Europa
holen und dann dort Probleme im Alltag
produzieren wir haben in Deutschland ja
diese berühmte Freibad Debatte in diesem
Sommer und in der kulminiert so ein
bisschen das All das Problem was aus
dieser Art Kommunikation
die auch deutsche sind
journalistenpolitisch korrekt
relativierend aber die Bevölkerung nimmt
das halt so war das sind arabische
Jugendliche die halt unseren Alltag
stark verändern und das wollen wir nicht
und man muss sich die Zahlen einmal
angucken wir hatten im letzten Jahr
962.000 Asylanträge in der EU wenn Sie
ein Dorf mit 500 Leuten sich anschauen
dann haben wir alle acht Stunden die
Gründung in Europa eines Dorfes dass du
90% aus muslimischen Männern auch
besteht natürlich ist dieser Art der
unkontrollierten Migration ein riesen
Problem weil wir helfen ja auch nicht
den wirklich Bedürftigen die wir holen
konnten oder die beschützen sollten wir
belohnen die die sich einfach
durchschlagen mit Schlägern oder mit
Geld und haben dann diese sozialen
Verwerfung deswegen Geschäftsführer der
Union Thorsten frei auch der ja diese
Woche gefordert hat dass man dann das
Grundrecht auf as abschaffen sollte ist
das richtig ihre Meinung dass der
richtige Weg ist aber die EU diskutiert
ja im Moment über eine Reform des
europaweiten asylbewerten das ist
richtig wir müssen uns Gedanken machen
wie beenden wir dieses massenhafte
sterben im Mittelmeer wie machen wir
humanitäre Korridore möglich und dann
eben auch für Frauen und für Kinder und
nicht für nur die Männer die sich eben
durchschlagen also es funktioniert das
System so nicht übrigens noch eine
Anmerkung zu Spanien ihre Thesen mit den
Volksparteien das sehe ich ein bisschen
anders nach den Umfragen wird die BP
wahrscheinlich 35 % bekommen
wahrscheinlich 28 oder 30 sogar bekommen
das sind zwei Drittel der Wählerschaft
wenn Sie das mal auf Deutschland also
wenn SPD und CDU zusammen noch zwei
Drittel der Welt hätte hätte
und in Spanien spielt allerdings das
haben Sie richtig beschrieben die
Migrationspolitik jetzt nicht die
Hauptrolle bei diesem der spielt auch
die Identitätspolitik und das Gesetz ja
ist ja und und die Folgen daraus eine
große Rolle
auf die auf die Niederlande die so viel
gerade im letzten Jahr wir haben eben
auch Bilder gesehen wo es so solche
großen Diskussionen gab weil man gar
nicht ausgerüstet war auch für die
Aufnahme von all den Flüchtlingen wie
mit welcher Hoffnung schaut man denn da
auf die EU und auf die Ideen in der EU
die Zuwanderung ja zu begrenzen und zu
steuern das ist so eine Sache anders als
Geschichte die EU hat Natur natürlich in
neue Pläne für Migration
die sind von der Politik aus begrüßt
worden ist endlich ein Durchbruch aber
zum Beispiel von
migrationsexperten auch schon kritisiert
worden z.B der Plan dass wenn man ohne
Papiere in Richtung EU kommt an den
Grenzen der EU auf aufgenommen werden
muss haben migrationsexperten auch schon
die Frage gestellt ja wer sagt wer wird
uns sagen dass das nicht neue
victoriaartige Camps geben wird wo diese
Leute auch sogar ganze Familien
aufgenommen werden
es sind natürlich
letzte Woche war das die Tunesien die
geschlossen die Hoffnung dass Tunesien
mehr machen wird um Flüchtlinge in
Tunesien zu behalten meine Kollegen sind
gerade zurück von einer Reise nach
Tunesien haben da gesprochen mit
Menschen schmuggele die gesagt haben ja
Bestechung ist bei uns weit verbreitet
das wird einfach weitergehen die die
Schiffe die wegfahren wollen die werden
wir irgendwie auf dem Meer schicken
können dass das bleibt so
und die Migranten die sie da gesprochen
haben die haben sehr viel Angst denn die
glauben
jetzt wird Zeit bezahlt
und keine mit uns machen was er will
also wir sehen das kritisch
Bemühungen der EU halt eben die
Zuwanderung anders zu regeln mit
Aufnahmezentren an den an den Grenzen
zum Beispiel gibt es da Punkte wo man
aus Ungarn sagt ja das ist ein richtiger
Weg ja ich denke dass man so hat was
aufstellt das war ein wo die Menschen
dann wo es gefragt wird angeschaut wird
wer dann Asylrecht hat
das finden sie richtig also Ungarn hat
sie hat nicht nur Ungarn gegen die
Verteilung der der Flüchtlingen und ich
möchte kurz darauf sagen dass Ungarn hat
diese Erfahrung von 2015 und das eine
keine Grenzanlage gab
sind der hunderttausende Menschen und
der serbisch ungleichen durchgekommen
und hat das Erlebte und das hat er es
hat so sprudeln hinter gelassen also am
besten wäre dass sie sehr sehr wichtig
für Ungarn und auch übrigens für die EU
jetzt nicht das verstehe ist dass man
die Fluchtursachen angeht also die
Ländern hilft woher sie kommen dass ich
es besser Ungarn hat hier hat hier
hungry have so ein Programm gestartet wo
Christen in diesen Ländern geholfen
werden aber nur speziell dann Christen
den also die den will man dann helfen
aber Muslime nicht also
eigentlich sehr vermischt weil alle
diese christliche Gemeinschaften sind im
muslimischen auch also die profitieren
auch davon also diese diese Bekämpfung
der Ursachen wäre sehr gut okay
ja ja ich ähm also ich habe über
europäische Themen lange berichtet und
jedes Mal
also seit 20 oder 30 Jahre man spricht
von dieses Asylpolitik bis jetzt man hat
überhaupt keine gemeinsame Asylpolitik
in Europa gehabt das ist schon etwas
dass man im Kopf haben sollte vor 20
Jahren weil das Situation nicht schlimm
die jetzt jetzt wir sind so von eine
Fluchtwelle von Leute die richtig Hilfe
brauchen
das kann man nicht verneinen man Europa
als Gemeinschaft man muss nicht diese
humanitäre Werte vergessen und das hat
die deutsche Innenministerin sehr
deutlich gesagt also
humanitär das ist die Hauptstadt die
hauptthemann obwohl natürlich diese
Menschenhändler natürlich dafür
profitieren
es wird es werden natürlich entsprechend
kommen von Ländern wie Marokko oder
Tunis oder Ägypten oder Libyen immer
wieder kommen um zu sagen wir brauchen
mehr Geld von Europa das ist wenig das
hat zum Beispiel Marokko gesagt also 500
Euro 500 Millionen Euro das ist nichts
aber immerhin wir müssen Menschen nicht
Flüchtlinge nicht Migranten sondern
Menschen die Frage ist aber ob man sich
darauf noch berufen kann in diesem
Europa ob das so noch funktioniert Herr
Weimar sehen Sie das noch als ein dieses
Fundament des Wertes das ja das
Humanismus dass man sagt man muss sich
mal umgucken in der Welt was gerade los
ist da ist Europa immer noch die
humanitäre Hochburg das kann man kann
man sagen und es ist sehe ich genauso
ein hoher Wert der mir verteidigen
sollten auch wenn die Politik natürlich
jetzt wie gesucht ich finde die anders
Abkommen mit Tunesien gut und zwar auch
aus einer europäischen Sicht weil es ist
das erste Abkommen was die EU selber
schließt und nicht einzelne Staaten
Spanier mit Marokko
ist
kommen das ist eigentlich eine
Vereinbarung keine Abkommen und das
müssen die 27 Ländern zustimmen
oder Polen oder doch in dem Fall alle
dafür
und die Umsetzung beginnt auch sofort
weil Tunesien braucht die eine Milliarde
weil sie in umschuldungswandlung mit dem
Währungsfond sind kurz vor der
Zahlungsunfähigkeit ich glaube dass
dieses Abkommen dazu führen wird dass
sich viel weniger Menschen von Tunesien
aus in die Fluten stürzen wir werden
dann auch weil es sich nicht mehr lohnt
du kommst ja nicht mehr nach Italien
damit werden auch viel weniger Menschen
sterben das ist erstmal ein positiver
Effekt die Kehrseite und ich finde gut
dass Europa gemeinschaftlich an wir
haben den Liberalen Route und wir haben
die rechte Meloni und die von der Leyen
die sind zusammen eingefallen also es
war auch ein gestoßen das Europa hier
gemeinsam etwas machen will und das ist
eben anders als man sich ja insofern bin
ich da zufrieden die Kehrseite ist
natürlich ist der Präsident von Tunesien
ein lupenreiner Demokratie
ist wenigstens ordentlich gewählt und
ist eine andere
Mann
dieser Mann verfolgt Homosexuelle dieser
Mann gibt Frauen keinen Erbrecht dieser
Mann behandelt Migranten richtig
schlecht also das ist natürlich die
Kehrseite aber wir bewegen uns in einer
Welt auch in Marokko der König ist ein
korrupter des Boot absolut und von
Erdogan wollen wir nicht reden also wir
müssen jetzt in der Realpolitik Deals
mit mit Typen machen die eigentlich uns
nicht gefallen aber das ist eher Politik
wo man jetzt da sind wir jetzt als EU
das wäre das vielleicht zu lange nicht
gemacht haben so viele Jahre und dass
man da jetzt einfach drüber hinweg
schauen muss
ich sehe das wenn das gelingen würde zum
Beispiel die Außengrenzen wirklich zu
schützen das wieder die die eigentliche
Lösung dass man diese Zustand nur so in
diesem Maße ausreichen würden also dass
die
Außengrenzen so eine Sicherung dass sie
gesichert werden auch kann ich mir
vorstellen so und so die bienengrenzen
so konnte
Familie Kontrolle in der innengesetz
sonst sehe ich nicht weil man dass man
diese Situation her wird es kommt darauf
an dass weniger kommen und wie möchte
man das erreichen es kommt drauf an was
weniger kommen aber trotzdem will man ja
das Recht für politisch verfolgt ist zum
Beispiel nicht einschränken oh nein nein
und das ist sehr wichtig nur noch eine
Bemerkung es ist wirklich schade dass
man jetzt kein meckenismus hat wo man
zwischen Flüchtlingen und Migranten
unterscheidet und es gibt kein
meckanismus auch in keinem Land auch die
EU hat das nicht und sehr viele Menschen
gehen da verloren und das will jetzt
zusammen behandelt müsste man kennen
eigentlich wie sehr setzt man auf die EU
bei der ganzen Diskussion um Migration
oder wie sehr denkt man in den
Niederlanden das müssen wir jetzt
einfach müssen wir hier im eigenen
Regeln ja die Frage ist natürlich
irgendwie weil man das auch im eigenen
Land klären kann denn immer natürlich
die europäische Gesetzgebung kommt
natürlich dazu was man sieht auch
mit dem Blick auf den Wahl in November
ist das viele Parteien die rechts oder
mehr recht sind sagen alle die bei uns
bleibt immer willkommen der wer jede der
wirklich Hilfe braucht
wie war es auch unstrittig ja das ist
unstrittlich ja
aber die Gedanken wie man das dann so
organisiert und was man will und was
auch geht zum Beispiel auch wenn es
wieder kommt zu dem Familiennachzug
letzten Sommer hat die Regierung schon
versucht an Pläne zu machen die die
Familiennachzug beschränken würden aber
davon hatte dass das wurde vom Gericht
abgelehnt so dass das ginge dann auch
nicht
also mal sehen wie das weitergeht sie
haben in Ihrem Land auch noch ein
anderes Thema nicht nur Flucht und
Migration sie haben eine Bewegung der
Bauern ja die sehr stark sich engagieren
und die eventuell sogar die stärkste
Kraft sein können das hat jetzt gar
nicht so mit Flucht und Migration zu tun
ist das auch ein Punkt wo man sagt da
rückten die Niederlande nach rechts
durch diese neue Bewegung ja na ja da da
ändern sich die Niederlande auf jeden
Fall was man im Zusammenhang mit Asyl
sagen kann für die Niederlande ist das
sehr viel Unzufriedenheit gibt im Land
und da kommen dann Themen wie Asyl die
Zukunft der Bauern aber auch die große
Mangel an bezahlbares Sozialwohnungen
kommen da alles zusammen das bringt eine
naja sie sehen sie da eine Menge von
unzufriedenen Leuten auf den Straßen die
die auch ihre Landesfahne umdrehen nicht
dass sie denken wir haben das irgendwie
wieder manipuliert
genau das ist bringt sehr vielen in den
Wahllokalen wir hatten das regional
waren und hat sehr vielen Wahllokalen
gebracht die aus Unzufriedenheit auch
für diese Bauernpartei gestimmt haben
die von Asyl und Migration sagen was ich
gerade sagte aber jeder der wirklich
Hilfe braucht ist immer jederzeit
willkommen aber sonst müssen wir
vielleicht darüber nachdenken wieder
weitermachen wollen mit mit Migration
und und da sieht man auch ein starkes
Gefälle zwischen Politik im in der Stadt
und auf dem Land ja genau also das dass
das so ein Thema der politische
Unzufriedenheit in den Niederlanden
vielleicht ist es auch in den anderen so
ist dass man sich so in die Stadt
eher links er progressiv auf dem Land
eher rechts eher konservativ und zum
Beispiel über den Bauern aber auch über
einige andere Themen wird diese
Unterschied zwischen Stadt und Land
immer klarer klarer als dass das war vor
zehn Jahren vielleicht war das
Unterschied auch da schon mal so aber
dann hat man es nicht wahrgenommen
vielleicht noch ein Gedanken weil sie
gerade das Wort progressiv für einführen
ich glaube wenn man jetzt jenseits ihrer
tagespol Umfrage Migration und
Rechtsruck mal schaut warum gehen
eigentlich so breite politische Gezeiten
das geht jetzt über viele Jahre und über
alle Länder so der Ruck nach rechts das
hat natürlich mit der Migration zu tun
aber ich glaube es ist eine kulturelle
Veränderung die tiefer geht ich erinnere
mich als Kind die 68er kamen und es war
eine linke Bewegung die war bereit über
kamen alle Länder hat eine Generation
geprägt und damals war progressiv was
links ist wenn sie aber heute Fragen und
die Jugendstudien zeigen das schon seit
vielen Jahren was empfindet die junge
Generation eigentlich als progressiv die
findet alles das progressiv was in
Kalifornien passiert was mit der
technikindustrie Elon Musk ist deren
schicke vara also während die 68
haben sie heute die jungen Generation
einen super Kapitalisten und das heißt
die Idee des Sozialismus als eine
egalitäre Gesellschaft die den
Kapitalismus überwinden die wird in der
jungen Generation überhaupt nicht mehr
als progressiv die denken da an dieser
Welt Nordkorea und deswegen ist dieser
gesellschaftliche Wandel viel tiefer
gesehen wir gehen da und kultureller
Generation hatte hat nicht die Chancen
dass wir damals hatten also die junge
Generationen besonders in den
schuttländer haben natürlich sehr viel
von diesen Austeritätspolitik gelitten
also ich glaube das sehen die ganz
anders
und werden Hefte
junge Leute heute wählen also
wahrscheinlich die links orientierte
Menschen auch die junge Menschen die
Links sind sind viele Skeptiker als die
rechtswelle die immer so wie Automaten
wählen egal ob die Politiker gut machen
oder nicht ne das ist eine Sache von
Selbstkritik zweitens
junge Generationen vielleicht ein paar
natürlich
haben es tatsachs oder Filmen gegründet
aber die meisten von denen haben keine
Chancen einen guten Job wie ihr Vater
oder Großeltern hatten die werden nur
ein pekarität wohnen die werden große
Schwierigkeiten eine eigene Wohnung zu
kaufen die werden große Schwierigkeiten
eine Familie zu gründen und das ist auch
ein eine Konsequenz von diesen sozial
reduktive Politiken die ihre letzten 20
Jahre in Europa geführt wurden
sehr unterschiedlich von Land zu Land
wahrscheinlich aber in diesen Südländer
ich kann nur sagen dass also die meisten
Leute überhaupt keine Chance haben einen
besseren Zukunft zu haben als ihre
Eltern oder Großeltern wie sieht man in
Ungarn diese Bewegung dass es eben jetzt
mehr Länder geht die nach rechts rücken
ist das was wo man sagt in Ungarn wir
waren vielleicht der Vorreiter oder sind
fühlen uns jetzt als Teil einer größeren
Bewegung wieder
ich denke an Vorteil oder ist bestimmt
dabei und
man sieht dass diese Fangemeinde von
Urban ist sehr sehr gewachsen und man
hat natürlich auch Meinungsumfragen wo
wo gezeigt wird dass viel mehr Menschen
jetzt die Migration oder die
illegale Migration ich unterscheiden
also insofern kann man das so betrachten
dass Ungarn dass ich bestätigt ja fühlt
weil viele dieser Vorschläge der EU
war ein Vorschläge die damals die
ungleichstelle gehen und gemacht als
damals 2015 dass man das machen soll und
sehr wichtig ich möchte noch darauf
hinweisen da gab es dann keine Grenze
2015 und da wurde eine Grenzanlage
errichtet in Ungarn und dieser
Grenzanlage hält oder bis jetzt weiter
2015 bis jetzt so fast eine Millionen
Menschen zurück die dann durchwerten die
dann aber in Griechenland oder woanders
ja genau
Bedingungen die werden dann in Ungarn
Gelände in Ungarn in Deutschland
gelandet oder in Österreich also sie
werden nicht in Ungarn betrieben und
diese eine Million Menschen hatten
Ungarn so frei gehalten von diesen
Ländern schau mal über noch mal ein
bisschen auf die EU was das bedeutet die
einen Zuschauer sind Manuela Seidel
fragt auf Facebook wenn die Situation in
Europa sich so weiter entwickelt sich in
zehn Jahren das vereinigte Europa als
Geschichte wie sehen sieht es denn vor
morsinghoff ist das ein Punkt wo man
sagt diese Entwicklung jetzt die kann
Europa auch dann spalten
ja das ist ein anderer Antwort liegt in
Zukunft wenn ich es von der Niederlanden
aus betrachte da ist natürlich dann
natürlich da ist wie in anderen
europäischen Ländern auch eine gewisse
eures Skepsis und ich kann mich
vorstellen dass Europa das ist für
Europa in den Niederlanden schwieriger
wird wenn zum Beispiel keine
einheitliche Asylpolitik gefunden wird
das muss man aber abwarten aber heute
war ja eigentlich ein wichtiger wurde
seine Position vom Ministerpräsidenten
wurde eigentlich immer stärker weil er
jetzt auch schon so lange
Ministerpräsident war in der EU ja das
ist auch nicht Frage wie seinen
Nachfolger oder seine Nachfolgerin das
machen wird was wird natürlich immer
gebracht hat er war ja so lange dabei
ja die Erfahrung in Europa und das fällt
jetzt weg ja nicht so skeptisch wir
sehen ja jetzt auch als Reaktion auf den
Krieg in Europa das so alte
Institutionen mehrfach für tot erklärt
wurden oder wir Journalisten auch in
Leitartikeln immer wieder das Ende
prophezeit haben wie NATO oder die EU
auf einmal ein großes Revival erleben
auch weil die Europäer merken was sie
daran haben an diesen Institutionen aber
dann muss Sicherheit und Freiheit
schaffen und ich finde die Europäische
Union ist das großartigste friedensbruck
was unsere Generation weil die
Generation unser Eltern eigentlich
geschaffen hat und die ist es Wert zu
Verteidigung deswegen freue ich mich
wenn in der Migrationspolitik nun solche
Sachen wie mit Tunesien und der eu-dach
eben gelingen und ich bin gar nicht so
pessimistisch dass das auch weiter der
Fall sein wird
wie sehen Sie was würden Sie sagen was
wäre das wichtigste auch gerade jetzt
Spanien als Ratspräsidentschaft als
Inhaberin der der Ratspräsidentschaft
worauf setzen man in ihrem Land auf wenn
man auf die EU schaut
ist kommt darauf an
was anderes also wenn dir die
Konservativen gewinnen sollten
ich kann nur schätzen aber also wir
wissen einfach nicht wer außer Minister
wird oder Innenminister
hat nichts über Migration gesprochen
also ich kann nur sagen also die werden
versuchen weil unsere Pflicht sein
sollte diese gemeinsame Politik bis Ende
des präsidentschafts zu bereit
vorzubereiten also wahrscheinlich mit
mehr Geld für frontext mit mehr Geld für
diese Länder mit Tunesien oder Ägypten
oder Marokko
man wird wahrscheinlich besser
definieren die Asyl Rechte die
Vorbereitungen für diese
Lager an der Grenze Europas wo diese
Prozeduren ob ein Mensch
das Recht auf Asyl haben kann also
dieses Asylverfahren durchgeführt werden
ja vielleicht werden also wie groß die
boxpartei sein wird
ja das ist die große Frage also man hat
teilweise mitträge hier gesprochen also
mit mit robusten also mit wobei man
sagen muss wir werden heute abend
wahrscheinlich Bilder sehen von einem
Wahlsieger Februar aus aus Madrid der
Mann ist nun kann der Mann ist nun kein
schneidiger rechter oder so der ist eher
so eine Art Boris rein Spaniens das ist
eher wenn mittiger klassische
bürgerliche Problem also den können sie
nicht mit Meloni oder sowas entscheiden
sogar die absolute Mehrheit und sie
brauchen dann diese
rechtsextreme Box gar nicht das Problem
ist dass er aus Galizien kommt und das
ist ein großes Problem weil die Leute
nicht
aber die Leute in Galizien haben große
Schwierigkeiten
sich zu definieren also man sagt bei uns
in Spanien also mit Galizia man weiß man
man weiß es nicht ob wenn du eine Frage
stellst und das Ja oder Nein ist das ist
sollte das ist zwischen die beiden
Portugiesisch
nach waren das ist besonders kompliziert
und das das ist das ist schwierig in
diese große Themen und große Konzepte
und definiert zu bleiben
die Frage ist die Frage ist Box sein
wird interessant ist
und interessant ist ja auch das vorher
es wurde ja nicht ausgeschlossen dass
man mit einer solchen extrempartei eben
zusammenarbeitet und das finde ich ein
natürlich das ist für uns ein Tabu ja
genau in Deutschland sagt man immer oder
sagt jetzt CDU ja auch ganz klar die
brandmaul zu erkennen
die Frage wie lange das bleiben kann in
den Niederlanden ist ist ganz anders da
hat man sich ja viel stärker geöffnet ja
nicht heißt dass man unbedingt mit der
PVV das ist die größte
rechtspopulistische Partei in den
Niederlanden dass man unbedingt
zusammenarbeiten möchtet
Ritter hatte sie in seinem ersten
Regierung versucht er hat einen
Regierung mit mit den Liberalen und eine
Christdemokraten gebaut und wurden dann
unterstützt von der
pvvis das hat nicht geklappt der hat
seine Unterstützung eines Tages
zurückgezogen und dann hat markgruitte
gesagt mit dir weil ich niemals wieder
regieren du bist nicht zu vertrauen das
ist aber mir dann das ging mir um die
Person will jetzt nicht unbedingt dass
man sagt dass man sich sozusagen
inhaltlich davon so abstellen auf
gewissen Punkten z.B in der asychologie
Migrationspolitik könnten die Liberalen
und die PVV irgendwie austauschen und
ähm
wir wussten immer solange es Marc Ritter
geben wird ist es wahrscheinlich
ausgeschlossen dass irgend auf
irgendeiner Art und Weise in der
Regierung zusammengearbeitet wird mit
der BVV jetzt ist markrütte weg und
vor einigen Tagen hat der
migrationspezialist von der VVD die
Liberalen also in einem Interview gesagt
naja vielleicht könnten wir das mal
wieder irgendwie versuchen mit der PVV
wenn die uns mal wieder unterstützen
würden in eine neue Regierung hat uns
sofort reagiert
wir können reden über alles aber da
möchte ich in der Regierung rein sein ja
und was würde das bedeuten wenn man
sagen wir mal in Spanien würde die
populär mit den mit der rechtsextrem Box
Zusammenarbeit in den Niederlanden der
ist vielleicht auch eine ähnliche
Konstellation was würde das denn dann
für Ungarn bedeuten die würden sich dann
weniger allein fühlen in der EU das
könnte sein aber ich denke die
Wahlen zu Europa-Parlaments sind
entscheidend wie viel dann wie viel da
reinkommen oder für Ungarn
ob da mehr rechte Parteien reinkommen
weil dann hätte er natürlich Ungarn
andere Mehrheiten oder da könnte sich
Ungarn dann hätte mir Unterstützer ja
weil man wie stark wie sehr denken sie
dass das in Deutschland so bleibt das so
so die Aussage der Brandmauer dass die
dass die steht also da glaube ich dass
die steht auch weil die CDU dass wir
Ihre eigene Integrität braucht und für
den macht Erhalt und dann macht er
überhaupt wiederum nicht braucht wenn
Sie schauen die letzten Wahlen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Größe des deutsches
Bundesland Brandauer stand CDU hat
gewonnen sie haben sogar in einer Stadt
wie Berlin gewonnen die eigentlich
wirklich links ist sie werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch in Hessen und in
Bayern gewinnen das heißt die CDU hat
das Problem gar nicht so sehr wie in der
öffentlichen Diskussion immer getan wird
wir wissen aus den Tiefen Analysen der
wahlwanderung viele der neuen Wälder der
AFD kommen gar nicht das sind alte CDU
wähle die kommen aus der Arbeiterschaft
zum Beispiel in den Arbeitervierteln
nach anderen Studie will sogar jeder
fünfte
Gewerkschaftsmitglied wie jetzt AFD
wählen das heißt die Milieus die sind
das ist nicht so da sind die
Konservativen und dann sind die rechte
und die wandern so durch sondern es geht
quer durch die Milieus die Gesellschaft
bricht sich um und für die SPD ist die
Frage mindestens so virulent die SPD ist
jetzt überholt worden von der AFD und in
ihren kernvideos in der Arbeiterschaft
brennt es gerade die haben eigentlich
das größere Problem sogar als die CDU
aber die CDU versucht ja jetzt auch ganz
klar mit vorschlagen wieder wie dem vom
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer frei
also Grundgesetz also Artikel 16A
abschaffen aber auch indem er jetzt sagt
also wenn jemand übers Mittelmeer kommt
dann müssen wir die retten aber die
müssen auch wieder in ihre an die
Grenzen wo sie von wo sich aufgemacht
damit zurückgebracht werden Karsten den
immer mit schnell Verfahren also ist das
eine richtige Antwort dass man sagt
versucht auf diese Art sozusagen
ihre Kern Identität der bewegt sich um
den relativ Sicherheit wieder ich sehe
das so die CDU war vor anderthalb Jahren
nach der Bundestagswahl ziemlich tot das
schwerst angeschlagen in Umfragen bei 17
18 19 Prozent auch intellektuell und
personell ausgebrannt und viele dachten
doch die geht den Weg der Demokratie
Christiana in Italien also die wird bald
nicht mehr geben die CDU und jetzt ist
die CDU in der Reha hat sich wieder
gefunden gewinnt Wahlen und ich würde
sagen in dieser Reha gibt es auch
verschiedene Phasen jetzt üben sie auch
ihr rechtes Bein wieder zu bewegen und
das ist das Bein von Lorent order und
schaffen dort Profil wie hat man denn in
Spanien das geschafft Profil zu schaffen
also für die bei der konservativen
Partei dass sie jetzt so gut darstellen
also ich glaube die Konservativen sind
jetzt auf den Weg zu einem Ziel dass wir
noch nicht wissen und das ist das
gefährlichste das also konservativ zu
sein das ist keine Sünde also die
Konservativen haben in Spanien regiert
und haben sogar gut regiert und man hat
auch gute Figuren in der Vergangenheit
gehabt aber jetzt diese konservative
Partei mit dieser Führer
das ist das ist das ist noch nicht eine
Definition klar also es gab
schadenkabinett das finde ich zum
Beispiel also ein bisschen merkwürdig
weil normalerweise immer waren
oder Außenminister oder wer
bitte aber hat man da versucht also wie
die Union jetzt
die CDU bei uns in Deutschland versucht
gerade ihr Recht ist bei mir zu bewegen
wie hat man da versucht die bestimmte
popular hat sie versucht ja einfach ja
auch mehr Law & Order zu betonen nein
weil es sich schämen also so weit zu
weit rechts zu gehen deswegen bleiben
diese Unsicherheit in diese
Lawine Situation die Frage wird nur sein
also wie die wenn wenn die peppe gewinnt
aber nicht genug ob wir dieses
Lieder der Ultra konservativen aber
Skala als der vertretende Minister haben
oder als Minister für Außenpolitik oder
ihnen Politik die werden natürlich
darum bitten und das ist die die große
Frage weil ein paar eine Partei die sich
nicht definiert das finde ich schon
merkwürdig besonders in diesem Moment wo
man Klarheit und viele Themen braucht
wenn es alles so offen ist für mich das
ist nur
das bringt mir Unsicherheit ich ich bin
nicht sage wir also ich umso umso
spannender auf die Ergebnisse heute
Abend zu können das ist es ist schon
Zeit für
die Ultra rechte oder die Extremisten
als salonfähig zu machen egal wo in
Europa das finde ich super gefährlich
das sind keine demokratische Parteien da
müssen wir darüber kämpfen es gibt
überhaupt keine Ausnahme von diesen
Partei die sind alle gleich Patrioten
Nationalisten
Antifeministen
Anti Europa also da sehen sie eine
Gefahr es ist Zeit für Sie liebe
Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen Liebe
zuhören ZuhörerInnen aber WDR 5 sie
haben Sie rufen uns an und sind auch
jetzt hier bei uns in der Sendung Ulrich
Klotz da habe ich ganz herzlich begrüßen
außer Frankfurt am Main schönen guten
Tag Herr Klotz und ihre Frage bitte
schönen guten Tag in die Runde weniger
eine Frage als eine Anmerkung oder ein
Vorschlag für ein Thema ich finde in der
ganzen migrationdebatte kommt eine eine
Punkt der eine Schlüsselrolle spielt zu
kurz und zwar die Kombination aus
schlepperindustrie und sozialen
Netzwerken bzw mobiler Kommunikation
also über die Smartphones in aller Welt
gehen ja Bilder die mit den Hoffnungen
geweckt werden in allen Teilen der Welt
und es ist bei der schlepperindustrie
ist ja unglaublich viel Geld im Spiel
und wenn die Leute dann hier ankommen
sind die natürlich gefrustet weil sich
das alles als Illusion rausfällt und
erzeugen dann die Reaktionen über die
hier auch schon gesprochen wird also die
frustreaktion und ich denke dass das bei
uns durch wirklich epochale Fehler in
der Politik
spätestens seit 20 15 viel Wasser auf
die Mühe in der schlepperindustrie
gegossen worden ist und die
Nachwirkungen sehen wir bis heute und
ich denke darum muss man sich kümmern
nicht ganz die ganzen Abkommen oder so
werden wahrscheinlich wenig bringen wenn
man diesen Schlüsselfaktor nicht angeht
und man muss auch den Link zu dem
aktuellen
Tricks Geschehen sehen ich denke die
flipperindustrie wird auch durch die
Leute gefördert die Interesse haben die
Europa durch Migrationsdruck zu
destabilisieren und nicht ohne Grund
wurden auch schon in Syrien und und
jetzt in der Ukraine zivile Ziele immer
gezielt bombardiert weil das
migrationsprogramm erzeugt und Belarus
ist ja auch zum Beispiel gewesen was da
gelaufen ist da kümmern wir uns viel zu
wenig drum wir sind immer an den
Arbeiten an den Symptomen an den Folgen
aber die Schlepper Industrie ist einer
der Schlüsselfaktoren das wollte ich
noch mal darauf hinweisen vielen Dank
Herr Klotz ich glaube das war aber schon
ein Punkt der auch gerade beim Thema
Tunesien sie haben sehr vorhin auch
schon angesprochen dass schon auch eine
Rolle spielte möchte jemand dazu noch
eine Bemerkung machen
der Zuschauer macht einen absolut
validen Punkt das ist auch ein
Kernargument warum die EU das jetzt
reformieren muss wir können die
Zuwanderung gerade unter humanitären
Gesichtspunkten nicht einfach der
größten Gewalt und den größten Geld
überlassen das kann ich der Maßstab sein
deswegen brauchen wir neue Verfahren ich
glaube aber das ist inzwischen über alle
Partei Grenzen hinweg auch in den
Parteien in der Mitte gekommen Seins
geworden
ja klar das ist das wenn es keine
Industrie gäbe dann wäre es auch nicht
möglich und um das Mittelmeer zu
überqueren aber ja wie macht man das das
braucht dann auch ähm was der Zuhörer
Zuschauer auch gesagt hat das braucht
dann eine extra Bemühung und um da was
zu machen und diese Verbrecher
das kann man nicht abschaffen also es
gibt Leute die Menschen nicht Mügeln
oder andere Art gibt eine legale Art zu
kommen muss braucht man ja keine Schmuck
mehr das ist ja eigentlich der Ansatz
der dahinter steckt ich glaube das ist
utopisch
da kommt man dazu zurück das ist sehr
wichtig wäre dass eine Mechanismus
geschafft wird wo man diese
Unterscheidung Macht zwischen illegalen
Migranten und Menschen die
suchen und dass man dies unterscheiden
kann und dann wieder für die Schmuggler
also dass wir auch für Sie eine ganz
andere Situation wenn man das
durchsetzen könnte und da müsste man
schon irgendwelchen Schutz haben
irgendwelche
Grenzen Schutz das dass man sieht dass
man unterscheiden können kann das steht
in diese Vorschlag von Ursula von der
Leyen ja ja genau diese Verfahren
Zentren an diese
grenzt starten vor die Leute die sich
identifizieren und registrieren damit
Sie das Recht auf Asien nehmen können
oder nicht ne und das dafür braucht man
und Rechtsanwälte und also das kostet
auch Geld aber das Gute das Gute ein
sehr gutes Geld Investition vielen Dank
Herr Klotz ich würde gerne Frau
Launhardt das Wort geben Liane Launhardt
aus Wedemark
in die Runde ich frage mich warum soweit
ich das überblicken kann überhaupt nicht
im Mittelpunkt der Diskussion das steht
was ich als
eingangsspurwechsel bezeichnen möchte
was meine ich damit dass man sowohl in
den Auslandsvertretungen wo Asylanträge
gestellt werden können als auch nach dem
Grenzübergang sofort die Möglichkeit den
Hilfe suchenden eröffnet sich statt für
einen Asylantrag für alle
zuliebe für eine Zuwanderung zu
entscheiden und damit das Asylsystem
ganz massiv entlasten würde und
gleichzeitig die
Zuwanderungsregelung auf andere Beine
stellen könnte als im Moment wo bei der
Zuwanderung ja sogar Fachkräfte aus
Ländern abgeworben werden und werden
sollen die diese selbst nötig immer mehr
gebrauchen das wäre meine Frage
vielen Dank Frau launert wer möchte
reagieren eines unsere Systeme sind
darauf gar nicht eingestellt wir haben
im Auswärtigen Amt ja im Moment
Krisensituationen in mehreren
Botschaften wo die bestürmt werden mit
Anträgen von Asylsuchenden
und nehmen wir mal an ihr Vorschlag
würde in die Wahrheit umgesetzt dann
würden sich vielleicht 42 Millionen
Afghanen im morgen bei der Botschaft in
Kabul melden das ist natürlich ein
praktisches Problem deswegen muss davor
die Entscheidung über die
Rechtsgrundlage
stehen und da hat von der Leyen recht
wir müssen das System reformieren die
Rechtsgrundlage darf nicht so
indifferent sein dass wir gar nicht
unterscheiden können zwischen einem
Wirtschaftsmigranten einem Kriminellen
ein wirklich schutzbedürftigen sondern
dass der gerade sich durchgeschlagen hat
der hat halt das Recht für alles das
musste geändert werden
vielen Dank Frau launert und ich würde
gerne Gerd Michler zu Wort kommen lassen
aus niederseifersdorf hallo Herr Michler
ja hallo ich grüße sie in die Runde
meine Frage betrifft die Anreize für
Flüchtlinge und Migranten vornehmlich
nach Deutschland und auf Spanien zu
kommen auf allen aber nach Deutschland
wir reden jetzt über besseren
Grenzschutz und so weiter und andere
Maßnahmen um das Problem was zu mindern
aber liegt das nicht auch an den starken
ökonomischen Anreizen und meine Frage
ganz konkret wäre es nicht möglich oder
ist es überhaupt möglich dass meine
EU-weit hier stärker Hand leid ich weiß
zum Beispiel dass in Polen viel
geringere Geldleistung gezahlt werden an
Migranten dass
dort auch ganz andere Anforderungen sind
und
von der Seite her ist mir jetzt auf der
Runde zu wenig gekommen
das Problem an sich
wo ich ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten habe
dass er mit der AFD in Verbindung zu
bringen
das kann ja jeder der die
Grundrechenarten beherrscht hatte ich
rausrechnen wenn Millionen von Menschen
nach Deutschland kommen dass es die
Gesellschaft zerreißt weil Berlin nicht
integrieren können und da muss man eben
über die Anreize auch reden denke ich ne
ja vielen Dank Herr Michler wie die
Anreize diese unterschiedlich sind auf
wie sie sind die Anreize in den
Niederlanden das ist auch ein sehr
beliebtes Land für ja das ist ein sehr
beliebtes Land das hat auch damit zu tun
dass wenn man es nicht genau weiß
Flüchtlinge meistens dass das Vorteil
bekommen also die die Aussichten in den
Niederlanden bleiben zu dürfen die sind
gut aber solange das Asylverfahren noch
läuft man darf zum Beispiel nicht
arbeiten man bekommt natürlich ein Bett
und eine Unterkunft und zu essen aber
sehr viel mehr ist es auch nicht ähm die
Frage ob man so leicht eine Wohnung
bekommt wenn man asylberechtige geworden
ist ist auch nicht sehr einfach zu
beantworten ich habe das schon
angesprochen die große Mangel an
Sozialwohnungen es ist auch nicht so
dass
Asylberechtigte dann eine gewisse Art
von Vorrang haben nein also ja
für die Niederlande spricht
wahrscheinlich natürlich die die sehr
gute ökonomische Lage des Landes im
Allgemeinen und auch das die Chance
bleiben zu dürfen ist auch relativ groß
aber bevor man wirklich Teil der
Gesellschaft ist und und
sehr Wohlstand hat das kann dauern wenn
das überhaupt gelingt und da wäre es
sinnvoll EU einheitliche Standards haben
aber die Lebenshaltungskosten sind
natürlich auch sehr unterschiedlich also
unterschiedlich aus Ungarn geht man
weiter nach Deutschland
wenn man eine Lage hat was nicht der
bewacht ist also wenn die Menschen frei
sind zu gehen dann bleiben einfach durch
weil in Ungarn sind die Sozialleistungen
viel niedriger
ist natürlich dass manche Staaten in
Europa mit besonders niedrigen Standards
auch ab wollen die die Flüchtling sagen
geht doch bitte weiter nach Deutschland
oder nach Holland und das ist eine
humanitäres Problem das geht so
eigentlich nicht natürlich ist das mit
den Lebenshaltungskosten ob sie jetzt im
Hinterland Rumänien oder in der
Innenstadt von München jemanden
versorgen müssen haben sie enorme
Preisunterschiede aber ich finde schon
dass wir europaweit einheitliche Regeln
haben sollte was Mindeststandards für
die Versorgung von Flüchtlingen betrifft
vielen Dank Herr Michler für Ihre
Anmerkung kommen wir zu Markus Hofmann
aus Bernau schönen guten Tag
Frau und zwar
eben wie gesagt es wird wahrscheinlich
die Fox
und die PP die wären sehr gewinnen und
eben wie es aussieht wird werden nicht
Sozialisten abgewählt was soll denn die
PP machen soll die dann sagen wir
koalieren jetzt mit den Sozialisten ist
damit der Wähler Wille abgebildet
und ja das ist eigentlich die Frage okay
wunderbar klare konkrete Frage an
danke für die Frage also eine große
Koalition in Spanien das kommt leider
nicht in Frage dass das wäre ideal wie
in Deutschland so konservativen und
Sozialdemokraten zusammen zu regieren
aber wir sind so weit weg von das und
sanche hat schon eine Koalition mit
dieser linksorientierte parteipodemus
gebildet und das kam also mit große
Schwierigkeiten daran es gab sogar
chaotisch also ich glaube
meine Meinung meine ganz persönliche
Meinung das ist auch eine Sache eine
Sache von patronismus also wenn Spanien
in eine so schwierige Lage sich findet
wie jetzt mit so viele
Herausforderung es wäre ideal so diese
große Koalition von konservativen und
Sozialdemokraten zu wilden aber die die
Interesse sind sehr unterschiedlich
der politische Hass unter die beiden
Parteien so groß ist dass das unmöglich
macht und auch zum Beispiel die
wirtschaftliche geschichtspunkte sind
ganz anders also wenn man mehr über
Justiz
Sozialausgaben um die Arme oder die
erweiter Klasse zu helfen oder wenn man
nur von Steuer runterbringen oder einem
mehr
klassistische Gesellschaft spricht dann
sind zwei unterschiedliche Welten das
kann man überhaupt kein gemeinsames also
nicht funktionieren eine groko wird in
Spanien nicht geben
vor ein paar Wochen Entspannung bei der
Regionalwahl und saß am Abend vorher
gebannt und hat beobachtet wie die
Wahlergebnis reinkommen und dann kam
eine Hochburg das Sozialisten nach den
anderen für die PP rausgegangen
Andalusien die groß steht unser altes
ieu ich glaube heute Abend sehen wir was
ganz ähnliches und vielleicht schafft es
die PP zu einer seiner absoluten
Mehrheit also ich hatte das für möglich
vielen Dank
Herr Hoffmann wir haben noch ganz kurz
Zeit für Hand Bob aus Mergentheim
schönen guten Tag
ja guten Tag
also meine Frage ist eigentlich ganz
einfach ich verstehe nicht warum die
ganzen europäischen Politiker wenn sie
mal richtig ehrlich wären ehrlich zu der
ganze Leute
ich war so oft im Ausland machen
nach Deutschland nach Europa wurde man
es geht deine Leute in Afrika so
schlecht in Ukraine oder sonst irgendwo
dass die nach Deutschland
ganz verständlich das ist doch für jeden
ganz klar zu sehr oder die in 45 Jahren
bin weil das wird meines Erachtens noch
viel schlimmer und es ist die Leute
schieße okay also sie haben Verständnis
für die Menschen die hier herkommen weil
man wie soll man dann mehr erklären ist
das ein Punkt hilft das
was die politische Lieder
erklären
er hat ja vollkommen recht das
Hauptmotiv ist natürlich ein
wirtschaftliches ich werde nur
vorsichtig dabei das vorzuschreiben in
die Zukunft häufig bitte das Bild gemalt
das wird jetzt immer schlimmer und es
kommen immer mehr und Millionen und eine
Völkerwanderung und Europa das muss
nicht so sein wir unterschätzen
vielleicht auch die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung in bestimmten Teilen der
Welt nehmen Sie mal Südasien Indien ein
armes Land vor 50 Jahren wird da haben
wir Hungerhilfe als als Kinder gespendet
und heute ist es an der aufschrieben der
mittelstandsindustrienation wird
überholt jetzt gerade China in dem
Bevölkerungsgröße und ganz Südasien hat
die hat es geschafft in in einen in
einen Wohlstand hinein Lateinamerika
übrigens auch und in Afrika wenn Sie
sich die neuesten Bericht des
Währungsfonds angucken die
Volkswirtschaften die am schnellsten
wachsen davon sind sechs in Afrika
Afrika ist nicht so dass es nur in der
Armut versinkt und da nichts passiert es
kann doch auch sein dass die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung sich umkehrt
und der Migrationsdruck nachlässt das
deswegen werde ich nicht so
pessimistisch mit der Prognose sie sind
nicht so pessimistisch wir sind am Ende
dieser Sendung und dieser Diskussion wir
schauen heute gespannt nach Spanien und
auf die Weiterentwicklung der EU ich sag
vielen Dank hier in die Runde und vielen
dank Ihnen für Ihr Interesse schönen
Sonntag
[Musik]